let's go next to Chuck from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Chuck welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
what's going on David can you hear me I
can
uh not really a question just kind of uh
giving you guys an update from uh PA
here since yeah
this uh important Senate race coming up
here yeah
yeah well so um yeah I live uh I don't
actually live in Pittsburgh I live south
of Pittsburgh about an hour but it looks
like really the only notable thing uh so
that's why I put that but I live in
Fayette County and it's pretty pretty
red here
um
but I mean it's just it's pretty
disgusting when I drive around like
um everybody's got all these uh
mastriano signs in there so it's got me
a little worried the only thing I you
guys or you cover like the uh the
polling yeah it's looking pretty good
right now for Shapiro
yeah it's looking good so that's that's
got my hopes up um I know that like when
I drive around like I said it gets me uh
a little worried just because you know I
live in like a red area so that's all I
see yeah
um but uh another thing uh I was at the
Washington County Fair which is actually
the county to the left of me
um and we say to the West is that what
you mean uh yeah to the west or left if
you were like looking on a map okay I
didn't know if you meant like left the
way you're sitting right now or
something like that oh no okay
um
uh but um as we were leaving the fair
and again I'm not a big Fair person I
just kind of went because I don't know I
haven't been in a while and uh we were
leaving and we're walking back to
through this like field to our car and
like the this family is walking out and
they got like three kids and they're all
I can't remember if they were I think
they were just waving either American
flags or uh like Doug mastriano Flags or
something but their kids were chanting
fjb and it was just a very very
disturbing sight to see like how old
were the kids I oh probably like nine
eight oh my goodness yeah it was like
very cultish
um but I it was pretty disgusting and
then another thing real quick is like
where I live I actually fly
an American flag off my house just to
kind of because like I feel like a lot
of Republican like you know if you're
not a Trumper if you don't support the
us or like if you don't fly a U.S flag I
feel like you're like looked at as like
a demon it's thinking Republican yeah so
yeah flag off my house to maybe you know
not get my house shot up or something by
an angry Republican that's not that I
mean you know the the Eggman who's a
Jewish Progressive but lives in Upstate
New York he wears flannels and grows a
big beard to try to blend in so I
understand
yeah I grow a beer I don't grow a beard
for that reason
um I actually just enjoy a beard but
yeah
um it actually does help uh fit in I
guess a little bit it certainly does all
right my friend thank you so much for
the call I appreciate it
yep no worries all right uh the
interesting calls today from all over
the place I'm uh I'm I'm liking it uh
let's see where do we want to go next
how about uh let's go to lahav from
Greensboro lahav welcome to the program
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
fine
okay I want to play a quick Fire game
we're gonna play a game now you and I
yes okay I list a politician and I want
you to say the first word you think of
to describe them okay let's try it
Elizabeth Warren
oh boy
uh buttoned up
uh Kirsten Cinema
confused
foreign
vicious
Jamal Bowman
don't know enough about him to really
comment with one word
um Mitt Romney
um
timid
um let's see
Steve scalise
uh pathetic
um Gretchen Whitmer
oh man Gretchen went work uh milk toast
um
AOC
passionate
Jill Stein
um very nice I guess
Jeb Bush
um Bush very nice how many more of these
are there by the way oh I'm sorry did
you see Jill Stein I thought you said
Jill Biden hold on Jill Style no Jill
Stein uh cuckoo
yeah that's better okay Tulsi gabbard uh
despicable
okay and um
let's see here let's stop let's leave it
there I think that's good that's a lot I
don't know that I have too many of these
left in me
okay thank you all right thank you very
much for the call appreciate it uh uh by
the way milk toast is
m-i-l-q-u-e for everybody who now is
looking that up but it's not it's not
like m-i-l-k milk like from cereal and
milk all right everybody let's take a
very quick break but we're still going
to take calls after the break so if
you're holding to chat with me hold on
just a little longer and I will
hopefully get to you quick break